The Last Guardian is out this week to
give to a giant stubborn yet lovable
companion called Treecko and ask you to
work with it to explore enormous ruins
and solve complicated puzzles should you
find yourself yawning for some general
tips to help you get by here's my advice
as someone who's finished the game the
last Guardians world is a series of
small sand boxes wherein you're
constantly trying to find the next way
forward sometimes this is obvious
sometimes it's a real [ __ ] what makes
it particularly hard is that at some
points only the boy can progress while
at others only Trico can progress and
sometimes it's a combination of the two
figuring out which is the first puzzle
my first piece of advice will seem
obvious but take your time and look
around especially up you'll be
constantly taking advantage of trackers
height so ledges that would otherwise be
unreachable are worth keeping an eye out
for conversely the boy is tiny so you
might be after a subtle crevasse in the
wall instead for the puzzles that need
to be solved by Trico sometimes it'll
approach them on its own and sometimes
you'll have to politely suggest your
buddy move it's after where you need it
trico is an AI that often has no
interest in playing nice so it's bloody
lucky he's cute
while you can train your pal to be more
receptive as the game goes on it still
pretty much only does what it wants when
it wants which makes directing it from
place to place kind of a nightmare
to this I'd say just be patient you
might have the right idea and he's
simply not listening to you immediately
if there's an obvious path available
trico will usually progress on its own
so if you're scouring the ground level
hopelessly aboard your giant draft bird
cat dog and hold on tight unfortunately
Trico doesn't speak whatever language
you speak so there's no what do you
think we should do next combos that said
you can read its body language to figure
out what to do next
trico is a pretty smart critter and it's
programmed by the game studio who
presumably wants you to move forward you
can generally find out what it's looking
at to discover we should be heading to
next also platforms with glowing blue
tiles indicate ledges you can turn
if trico is refusing to move he might
just be imitating your family's cat and
being a huge furry [ __ ] or he might
not be able to progress for an
environmental reason so make sure he has
room to move forward and check up on how
he's doing emotionally by watching for
physical cues that show off emotions
like anger fear or hungry now on to some
health and safety suggestions do not
assume tracker will always catch you
when you jump from a great height
sometimes it will sometimes you'll break
your leg and desperately cry out to try
Co what I'm assuming that's an accurate
translation while being pursued by nasty
stone warriors jumping away as soon as
you get to your feet is the best option
I also recommend you stay as far from
the ominous blue doors as possible those
are the freaky portals that are nasty
guys are trying to drag you to and if
they get you in there you are done
that's that wrestling your way out of
their clutches really isn't too hard
you're unlikely to have trouble but if
you do feel free to enact my technique
that I use in both the Last Guardian and
every fighting game I've ever played
that is mash all the buttons the sound
of music would suggest you climb every
mountain and Ford every stream in the
Last Guardian it's more like flip every
lever grab every grabbable thing and
crawl inside every tiny boy sized hole
but the sentiment is the same the
climbing and platform traversal can be
frustrating due to the weight and
momentum of the boy that's not a tip I
just want you to know it's not your
fault if a solution seems too
complicated you're probably over
complicating it explore all the
available areas and verticality z'
before deciding the trick is to climb a
bumbling and non-compliant trico and
jump to that tiny almost indiscernible
outcropping of wall which doesn't seem
to actually go anywhere but might be
just what you need to get to the next
area
finally if after all that you're still
stuck you can always go ahead and blame
the camera angles the lighting that
drops out at random the traversal bugs
all try COEs AI that said the Last
Guardian is an absolute delight and
hopefully these tips relieve a bit of
the frustration so you can appreciate
the gorgeous game world and the touching
bond between a boy and his bird cat dog
you